let's give ourselves a little bit more
practice adding and subtracting positive
and negative numbers so let's say that
we have the statement four is equal to
negative eight minus blank like always I
encourage you to pause the video and see
if you can figure out what blank would
be to make the statement true that
negative eight minus blank is going to
be equivalent to 4 that 4 is equal to
negative eight minus blank so now let's
work it through it together and to help
us I will get a number line so there's a
number line right over there and one way
to think about it is I want to start at
negative 8 so this is negative 5
negative 6 negative 7 negative 8 I want
to start at negative 8 and I want to do
something to negative 8 to end up at 4
to end up at 4 so 4 is positive 1 2 3 4
so that's 4 right over there so what I
needed what do I need to do to get from
negative 8 to positive 4 well let's see
I have to move to the right 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 I have to move to the
right 12 spaces
another way to think about it to get
from negative 8 to positive 4 I have to
actually let me make sure I have some
space up here I have to add 12 another
way to think about it to get from
negative 8 to 0 you have to add 8 and
then to get 2 from 0 to 4 you have to
add another 4 so you have to add 8 plus
4 or 12 but how do you do that because
they're saying negative 8 minus
something should be equal to 4 well
whatever you have over here you want
this to end up being equivalent to plus
12 so what can you do there well you
could subtract a negative if you
subtracted negative 12 this would be
equivalent to adding 12 so notice let me
rewrite it 4 is equal to let me just
write it without my boxes there is equal
to negative 8 minus negative 12 but what
happens when you subtract a negative
well that ends up being adding the
positive so this is going to be the same
thing as negative 8 plus positive 12 or
4 is equal to negative 8 plus 12 which
we know is true you add 8 you get to 0
negative 8 plus 8 is 0 and then you add
another 4 you get to positive 4 so that
one was pretty interesting let's do
another one we can't get enough practice
this is too much fun
all right so let's say we had let's say
we had something blank minus negative 2
is equal to negative 7 how do we think
about this well the first thing my brain
wants to do is to simplify subtracting a
negative so if you subtract negative 2
that's the same thing as adding positive
2 so this is an equivalent statement to
saying something subtracting a negative
2 is the same thing as adding a positive
2 something plus 2 is equal to negative
7 and now we can get the number out
number line out to think about it so get
my number line out so my goal my goal is
I want to get to negative 7 so it's
negative 5 negative 6 negative 7 right
there and I want to add 2 to something
to get to negative 7 so if I'm adding 2
that means I'm jumping to I'm jumping to
to the right that's what adding 2 looks
like so what number do I need to start
at that if I jump to to the right if I
add 2 I end up at negative 7 well I
would have to start to to the left of
negative 7 if I start to to the left 1 2
if I started let me do this in a
different color if I started this number
right here and if I add 2 plus 1 plus 2
plus 2 I end up at negative 7 well what
number is this this number that is 2 to
the left of the negative 7 well that's
negative 9 so this right over here is
negative 9 negative 9 plus 2 so if you
start at negative 9 and you move to to
the right you end up at negative 7 or
you could say negative 9 minus negative
- because if you subtract negative -
you're going to move to the right if you
subtract positive - you move to the left
but then if you subtract negative - you
move to to the right to negative seven
another fascinating one let's do one
more of these and I'm having maybe a
little bit too much fun all right so
let's say we have negative four is equal
to blank - 9 so let's get the number
line out and always pause the video see
if you can try it on your own but let's
let's get my number line out and so
let's think about it our goal we want to
take some number subtract nine from it
and get negative four so we want to get
negative four and then there's some
number that if we take nine away from it
so if you take nine away from something
that's moving nine to the left so
another way to think about subtracting
nine let me do this in a different color
subtracting subtracting nine that's
literally moving nine to the left one
two three four five six seven eight nine
so there's some number that we start
with we're going to subtract nine and
then we end up with negative four we're
going to end up with negative four some
number some number that's the blank
right over here you subtract nine you
move nine to the left that's going to be
equivalent to negative four so another
way to think about it is this number is
going to be nine to the right of
negative four so let's think about what
that number is going to be so this
number is going to be nine to the right
of negative four one two three four five
six seven eight nine it looks like
positive five so let's let's let's see
if we're right about that fight if we
start at positive five and we subtract
nine so let's do that one two three four
five six seven eight nine yep you
subtract nine you're going to end up at
negative 4 so negative four is equal to
five minus 9